as socialists empty heads insists that
the economy isn't working a record high
number of Americans are working because
the economy is absolutely soaring we
will analyze the greatest jobs producer
God ever created and the threats that it
faces then I know you'll be shocked to
hear this Jim Acosta is complaining some
more Owen Benjamin stops by that huge
pianist friend of ours and Pope Francis
changes church teaching on capital
punishment we will analyze the many
wonderful benefits of killing criminals
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a lot to get to in one day we're
gonna have to do it that we're gonna
have to cover everything from how
wonderful capitalism is to questioning
certain changes that are coming out of
the Roman Curia and out of the Vatican
certain things that seem a little
strange you know there's a difference by
the way when people a difference between
Protestants or more evangelical
Christians and Catholics is when brought
more Protestant leaning people a
question their pastors or questioned
their their denominations teachings they
can be pretty vocal about it they can be
pretty straight on and when Catholics do
it we say well is it perhaps the case
that the Holy Father is mistaken is it
is it I wonder if I am misunderstanding
the Holy Father we will have to see if
we're misunderstanding the Holy Father
on the death penalty before all that you
know another promise has been kept
President Trump he promised us do you
remember this he's made a lot of
promises everyone laughed at him he said
he's ridiculous that'd be crazy
everything was gonna go terribly if he
were elected he promised us that if he
were elected he would be the greatest
jobs president that God ever created I
remember when he said it well that's a
really bold statement turns out that has
absolutely been the case
president Trump take it away I'll be the
greatest jobs president that God ever
created so there's a great spirit going
on right now a spirit that many people
have told me they've never seen before
ever we're gonna create jobs I said that
I will be the greatest jobs producer
that God ever created and I mean that I
really I'm gonna work very hard on that
all right we're a year and a half in
let's see what is the record show the
record shows that in the month of July
the most recent month that we have
numbers for a record high number 155
million nine hundred sixty-five thousand
people were employed in the United
States that is an all-time record high
but by the way that's the 11th record
breaker since President Trump took
office this is true by the way the the
way that Democrats and socialists try to
spin this is they say well the economy
is working really well for some people
but it's not working well for all people
and this is when they try to demagogue
on issues of class division or race
division or sexual division or whatever
but as even when you look at all of
their divisive categories the numbers
still hold up we have record low black
unemployment we now have a record low
Hispanic unemployment in the United
States this is the second record because
he's at record low Hispanic unemployment
two months in a row last month the
economy added 157 thousand new jobs and
unemployment has fallen below three
point nine percent to put that into
perspective economists consider an
unemployment rate of four to six point
four percent to be full employment
because if you're in a system that has
freedom you're gonna have some
unemployment people are gonna be
changing jobs you might you know a
company might fire somebody who's not
doing a good job and then they'll find a
job that they're better at so four to
six point four percent is considered
full employment and we now have we are
now looking at an unemployment figure
below that we have more than full
employment in this country and President
Trump predicted it he said that would
happen but why is that happening because
he said I'm the greatest jobs president
God ever created that might be true I've
been been on the numbers that is true
but then he said I'm the greatest jobs
producer that God ever created and that
isn't quite true he's the greatest jobs
president but he's not the greatest jobs
producer the greatest jobs producer is
capitalism its economic freedom this is
and it's a wonderful time to be seeing
these numbers because you have the rise
of socialism across the United States
we've talked about how the Democratic
socialists of America have increased
their membership Eightfold in just two
years the majority of Millennials
consider themselves socialist at the
same time we are seeing that economic
freedom economic liberty capitalism
creates jobs it creates prosperity this
is the first time that we've seen this
in our political lives as Millennials
and it's impressive to see because what
why is President Trump the greatest jobs
president that God ever created because
he is increasing freedom and decreasing
regulation he is letting people keep
more of their money by lowering taxes
historic tax reform on companies and on
individuals
he's deregulating the federal government
so he's making it harder for these
bureaucrats and Technik rats to control
every aspect of
our lives he's opening up a trade is
negotiating better trade deals he's
trying to get better trade deals where
we're drilling baby drilling we're now
the biggest exporter of oil in the world
we're producing energy you know during
the Obama administration we would hear
no you can't drill here you can't
transport oil or natural gas here you
can't do this you can't do that no no no
no no and what President Trump did very
simply perhaps just on his gut is when
he got in he said we are gonna unleash
this economy we're gonna unshackle it
we're gonna open up the bonds that are
holding this economy back and this thing
is gonna roar and it is roaring this
economy should have been roaring years
ago because well you had that recession
in 2007 2008 and after steep recessions
you should have a steep recovery but
President Obama just put shackle upon
shackle so what a president Trump - he
opened that up he unleashed it freedom
works freedom works so it's it seems so
simple I think even conservatives need
to tell ourselves this sometimes because
sometimes we conservatives you know we
get a little a little contrarian a
little a little Tweedy a little
traditionalist you say oh I don't know
about freedom I don't well you know
pish-posh
know freedom works very simply it works
economically we're seeing that with all
of these numbers it works politically it
works creatively when you when you
unshackle people they are free to be
creative they're free to do what they
want and this is true as a matter of
political speech the accusation against
President Trump in this administration
is that he's authoritarian oh he's
authoritarian he's he's a fascist he's
authoritarian
now see an authoritarian by letting
people say and do whatever they want you
know one of the observations of this era
in politics is people are sort of
frenzied they're vocal that they're
politically engaged the federal
government is not stopping them the
authoritarian so-called government isn't
stopping anybody from doing that you
know people are out there screaming
they're angry they want impeachment they
want this they want that the president
doesn't tell anybody to stop doing that
the freedom of the press has not been
abridged the freedom of the people to
speak their minds has not been abridged
there is freedom out there and by the
way even with all that screaming and all
that fake news and all
at Aunty administration rhetoric coming
out of the mainstream media the
administration's approval ratings are
50% they're doing very very well because
people when you give them freedom when
they say look you can speak and you can
speak and you can speak battle it out it
gets really loud it gets really raucous
it's not orderly it's not quiet it's not
it's not couth but it's really raucous
and people can get a semblance of the
truth this is a wonderful thing
some people are not thrilled about this
though and by some people I of course
I'm referring to Ron Burgundy himself
Jim Acosta Jim take it away Sarah's
question from NPR she asked you about
Ivanka Trump's statement that the press
is not the enemy of the people and she
asked you whether or not the press is
the enemy of the people you read off a
laundry list of your concerns about the
press and things that you feel like are
misreported but you did not say that the
press is not the enemy of the people and
I I think it would be a good thing if
you were to say right here at this
briefing that the press the people who
are gathered in this room right now
doing their jobs every day asking
questions of officials like the ones you
brought forward earlier are not the
enemy of the people I I think we deserve
that president has made his position
known I also think it's ironic my oh my
god I'm trying to answer your question I
politely waited and I even called on you
despite the fact that you interrupted me
why calling on your colleague I said
it's ironic and which is why I
interrupted I'm trying to view if you
finish if you would not mind letting me
have a follow-up that would be fun but
it's ironic Jim that not only you and
the media attacked the president for his
rhetoric when they frequently lower the
level of conversation in this country
repeatedly repeatedly the media resorts
to personal attacks without any content
other than to incite anger the media has
attacked me personally on a number of
occasions including your own Network
said I should be harassed as a life
sentence that I should be choked ice
officials are not welcomed in their
place of worship and personal
information is shared on
Internet when I was hosted by the
Correspondents Association of which
almost all of you are members of you
brought a comedian up to attack my
appearance and call me a traitor to my
own gender in fact as I know I'm as far
as I know I'm the first press secretary
in the history of the United States
that's required Secret Service
protection the media continues to
ratchet up the verbal assault against
the President and everyone in this
administration and certainly we have a
role to play but the media has a role to
play for the discourse in this country
as well preach preach Sarah yeah baby
so Ron Burgundy Jim Acosta leans in
there and he says listen you we have
freedom of the press in this country you
need to respect the press you need to
respect the freedom of the press and
that's why you need to tell all the
American citizens to shut up why won't
you why won't you tell them to shut up
they're saying me and things about me
Sarah stop them and Sarah Sanders is
saying like well that sounds like a you
problem Jim Acosta that certainly
doesn't sound like a me problem says no
say it say it and I love the idea of
this by the way that Jim Acosta you know
just a guy built in a lab for CNN he's
there he's saying hey listen lady say
what exactly what I want you to say and
she says no I'm not going to do it and
then the left is outraged because a
woman wouldn't say what Jim Acosta told
her to say and she is exactly right by
the way she has been pilloried she has
been attacked the she's the first press
secretary in history to require a Secret
Service protection and she says no we're
not gonna have that we're gonna let you
Jim well first of all it's incredible
that they still call on Jim Acosta I
love that they do because I think every
time Jim Acosta speaks Trump's poll
numbers go up three percent but they
they call on Jim Acosta they don't ban
CNN they don't censor CNN and then what
she's saying is not not only do you get
to speak Jim but your critics get to
speak to that's how this works that how
this that's how this freedom is gonna
work and and to hear the media whine and
moan it's as though they've never been
attacked before they've never know this
is unprecedented no no no maybe Jim
Acosta hasn't been attacked but what
about Fox News here's a clip from ten
years ago I think was 2008 of a mob
swarming Fox News check it out
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm sorry if that sounded like a fire
alarm to you if they have to bleep out
every every second and a half every
millisecond they're gonna beep beep yes
warming them you know che guevara
t-shirts on you know saying no borders
no this no that they're swarming they're
saying F FoxNews F FoxNews that's a lot
worse than Jim Acosta ever gotten that's
a lot worse and you didn't really hear
people complaining about it then did you
but freedom works freedom works in the
left is really nervous about this you've
got finally this honest debate we're
talking about the honesty right now of
the midterm elections you have Democrats
who are coming out and honestly saying
yeah we're socialists we want socialism
we don't like freedom we want socialism
then you've got a Republican a
conservative administration that's
saying have freedom have it we're gonna
unshackle the economy you get economic
freedom we're gonna unshackle political
discourse you're gonna have political
speech you're gonna have freedom of
speech Duke it out do you want freedom
or do you want slavery that's the
question that Owen Benjamin has dropped
by the studio to answer oh and what's up
you've been hiding quietly there since
since we've been doing that entire
second sitting on a pond the whole time
Jim accosted so that's what I got am i
right yeah what about you and ladies and
gentlemen to see you
I why didn't I have you write this the
title for yesterday's episode about Jim
Acosta Jim Acosta I just started it now
because when I'm told to be quiet for a
bit I do a lot of really good thinking
and puns this is why you make the big
bucks and I'm sitting here in a broom
closet yeah this is why I'm I'm I'm look
like a mime I just got off a plane I'm
like I was in a mine I'm here I've
that's what you're doing sitting
silently well can I be the verbal mine
where I'm like I'm in a box
in case you don't realize it this is a
box sucks I am a mime don't forget to
tip me yeah look it's a rope it's not a
chain so you're in town are you just you
just came here to mime and hang out what
are you doing in town it's a good mind
you know well it Bret I was gonna go to
prankers birthday party and I'm I just
did that preggers you've it so I just
stopped by are Corollas place and then
you and
just hanging out that Praeger you video
was fantastic thank you who haven't seen
maybe we'll have to add in a video of
this it's you talking about the death of
comedy sharing about what's happened to
comedy and so you shot the video a while
ago and then in the mean time between
your shooting the video and now Netflix
came out with the Nanette aunty comedy
comedy special I want to do an anti
plumbing plumber it's like you know I'm
here to fix this pipe because human
excrement is spraying everywhere but I'm
just I was raped once so I'm gonna go
home and just you're gonna drown like no
like no other job that could even
possibly be it's unbelievable you say
the I am I thank you for paying money
everybody I am explicitly gonna do the
opposite of my job right for those of
you thinking that I just brought up the
rape thing to be a weirdo that's what
she said so I was like referencing what
she was like trying to reference these
horribly dark things and then why that's
why she will not do comedy as she's
being paid to do come what will say you
did have to clarify that because I'm not
a soul on earth has watched that comedy
special comedy comment well except for
their friends sending the trailer being
like what is this oh wow yeah that you
know it's true it would be like Jim
Acosta getting on TV and spreading real
news you can't do that's not his job no
rationale yes to act like a
schizophrenic donkey all the time
just hee-hawing and kicking and acting
just ridiculous you know so this topic
that I've been thinking about all week
is freedom works freedom it is working
it's working politically it's working
economically this ties into your video
right this guy's into like this
oppressive you don't laugh nothing's
funny don't there's that culture and
then there's the culture of breathe the
sweet air of freedom have a laugh have a
chuckle yeah it's about consent you know
it's like that's why it's so rape you
can - laughs no way is it about consent
free markets its consent it's like I
want to work with you you want to work
with me let's make both of our lives
better that consensual relationship and
then you have socialism which is at the
end of a gun I will set I will establish
the price of bread without any factors
like there really is an element of force
versus consent and that seems to
permeate people's entire lives the left
I mean
we've seen this now all these stories
come out of these like the feminist good
guys the soy Boy feminist yeah they are
by far to create the creepy ones with
girls they follow them around and Harvey
Weinstein obviously the me to movement
maybe there's something to this theory
there it's the coercion of the left it
makes them feel entitled to take
whatever they want right because what
they're doing doesn't actually help
women in fact it's horrifying what it's
like you know what being a woman is lots
of abortions you know work 90-hour weeks
now to get married to you guys in 50
years like that's that's someone who
actually loves a woman and you know we
just had our second child
congratulations get it the last thing I
would do is establish a fake wage gap
she what she has her master's in
engineering my wife's a brilliant woman
who wanted to stay home and be a mom and
and just push her into the salt mines of
you know and then just and say like
abortions empowerment and all this stuff
and then secretly they're just up to no
good these guys yeah yeah that's
absolutely right that element of
coercion where do you see it though I
mean because I'm interested in from a
cultural perspective and a political
perspective so the midterm elections
right now are being they're pretty
honest do we want to keep Trump do we
want to impeach Trump yeah you want
freedom do we want socialism you've got
these socialist candidates where is it
heading culturally are we gonna get more
Nanette's are we gonna get more anti
comedy I think there's gonna be a lot of
division but I think there's more
conservatism happening with young people
but there is that millennial generation
that just has all this dead and no
purpose and they really the problem I
see is that the sewed the the evilness
of socialism that whisper like I'll take
care of your debt yeah you know they're
like really because they're so like they
can't default on it they were my parents
of professors and they warned me about
this a long time ago where they're like
this is going bad you know the devaluing
of the of the college education where
they're just wetting at anybody anyone
can get a loan yeah no more enjoyed
knowing on it nothing nothing yeah and
my parents both taught things like
actual things not this like underwater
lesbian ballet they they didn't teach
that oh they're clearly my dad has games
beyond that as one of his cases yeah no
but they're just giving people
kontin sir actually I read somewhere
that if you study economics right now in
college you leave knowing less like for
real because your basic thoughts are
better than this Marxist knots then what
it's being replaced with yeah and it's
weaponized empathy to where it's like I
see the trick I see like don't you love
poor people it's like but socialism
isn't about supporting the poor it's
about destroying the rich it's an envy
based evil ideology and it's it once you
see it you're like well you you had that
great video that came out the last
Bernie bro oh yeah where we'll have to
put a link to it because it's something
like it's like a four-minute video right
so pretty long yeah and and the last
Bernie bro spoiler alert is it's living
in Venezuela yeah yeah I guess mission
he's like I brought my you know my
machete make sure he pronounced it the
way that and then you know he's got
bubbles as frisbee into akua's and a
vape pen he's like I'm gonna go where
the utopia is and of course it goes to
Venezuela and my friend who's playing
the guard is not even looking that
direction it's only in Venezuela hey
just you know spoiler it's only four
minutes long but he steals my passport
and I just have to stay in Venezuela
it's this extended childhood there's no
you know meritocracy is scary if you
have no skills and you're raised with no
values of course and that's such an
interesting point there in the video
like it tells you a lot about the
country to go down to the border and see
which way the guns are pointing oh yeah
it's you will hire my buddy we're
talking about that we're like there is
no socialist country in history where
people are trying to sneak in ever right
there's always raps coming out of Cuba
nobody in Miami is like I'm gonna flow
it on a tire and get to Cuba it's never
ever happened so why would we want that
like North Korea no one's running in
that's right that's except all the Stan
countries no one's trying to go into you
know the stands are not good dudes you
know
Stanzi well yeah cuz I'm actually direct
those guys down afghanistan-pakistan did
Stanley man Stanley's not gonna do I'm
watching up Handmaid's Tale and I
thought I would hate that thought I was
gonna be anti conservative propaganda
it's fine dude it's awesome it's about
Islam no look I'm dead serious I'm
watching this thing and I'm like this is
accurate Islam stuff yeah yeah even
gentle mutilation is in it covering the
faces eight wives it's literally like
I'm watching this I'm like how is this
spun to be anti-christian this is a way
when historians when you're looking back
to figure out when the moment was that
we all started to get jihad it was this
moment when Owen brought it up on the
show yes was the beginning of of us a
dealing why are getting jihad it thank
you very much and I appreciate that you
guys see my artwork of Muhammad and
various horses now it's I don't yeah
it's it's it's it's not it is I know I
actually I agree with you I I've enjoyed
watching Handmaid's Tale because it is
just trash I mean it's it like a trashy
show yeah but you look at it the people
on the left earnestly believe that that
is where the United States under Donald
Trump is headed but I think it's like a
psychosis because they don't see that
they're almost accurately picturing
socialism and the Uglies caliphates and
stuff like it's not at all what the
right wants of course like it's all
coercion it's all there's no free
markets in the head it's like yeah you
know and and that's that's the irony
about this whole thing as they say what
they're you know I clearly Hillary
Clinton ad so I'm going out with Russia
cuz this whole nonsense is coming from
some weird projection it's like the
closet gay guy with like eight z28 you
know dude why'd you go camping with a
dude okay you got you were like are you
gay you know I sleep with a man what are
you
I know then you're like what why are you
going so far and then the left
everything they're like going so far
with you're like that's you yeah
absolutely I mean you even see when Jim
Acosta when Ron Burgundy is yelling at
Sarah Sanders he's saying their premise
is that the Trump administration is
authoritarian and all Jim Acosta saying
is tell people not to do anything tell
people not to talk tell people not to
criticize me say we don't do that right
that's what you do you you tell people
to shut up we don't course and the of
course the irony is if it really was
what they described they'd all be dead
and they would never be able to say it
right like the one way you know for a
fact the media isn't actually being
attacked in America and this is not a
fascist government is because you can
hear them talk about that right console
incessantly oh and it's just like
comfort with cognitive dissonance like
Trump is Hitler give him your guns like
my stuff you know submit to tolerance
like these things that any child could
see their cut the comfort in it has to
come from post-modernism where it's like
there is no truth in the world because
if not how do you function that way yeah
like up down like up is down down is up
but just this is my question with the
Millennials and I honestly don't know
which way it's going to go that the
signs don't seem good you know more than
half of Millennials identify as
socialist they skew Democrat all these
things but this is basically the first
time in their lives and they're
politically conscious lives that they've
seen prosperity yeah they're seeing
right there seeing freedom their
rhetoric sounds very Pro freedom is
there any way you do you think that we
can get them back or they all just oh
yeah yeah yeah we can talk about a lot
of it is cultural too I think a lot of
young men don't have any strong male
role models that's why they're drawn to
people like you and Shapiro and Jordan
Peterson and we're so masculine
you know we're just so we're so like but
when and the Barbarian the other thing
we're talking before about how you were
like the most manly guy yeah that's
right it's only because like I I would
wear oxford shirts every so often you
know I wasn't wearing a dress all day
you know he's not wearing mascara must
be lumberjack mister you think like guys
I have never thrown a football in my
life yeah that's right but there is a
sense of that in the culture in the land
of the blind the one-eyed man is king
we're I'm doing a speech for ya in the
fall which is how to be a man when you
look like a Maddow and there are just
very simple things that you can do but
that's a very that's it quality you just
did that people want what you can mock
yourself yeah right you know the other
thing they're so precious these the
Millennials they're so shocked when you
I don't know when I interact with guys
I'm a jerk you know yeah I make fun of
each other and and you make fun of your
own weaknesses or your own things that
like I was I was laughing out loud when
Shapiro is making fun of how he does ads
yeah that's so male that's so a normal
male behavior where I would make fun of
my size I got my oh girl you know like
like and and and sometimes people don't
get that and they they want it so bad
again because they're like that relieves
our pressure that's what my preview
video is about that's right where it's
like this pressure is building where no
one could just mock each other yeah and
then it just explodes and and I think
that there is no mockery on the left
it's all because it's fundamentally such
a lie that they can't ever be in their
own skin anymore they can't just be free
and criticize each other like me and you
could have an argument over policy and
our friendship wouldn't be affected at
all in the least that's exactly right
yeah but for the left when you attack
their political opinions they actually
say this they say you're erasing me
you're erasing my identity
you're invalidating me like you really
it's like sometimes I want to be like
that dudes never seen a dead guy show
you a race person it's horrifying you
know it's kind of like it's these people
are almost doing live-action roleplay
with stuff they don't understand yeah
one time someone is saying words or
violence and I have two kids now I don't
wanna go to jail or anything but I want
to just just just just go like this and
be like which one do you want my word if
you want me to seriously knock your face
off your body do you wanna do you want
to see how words are not violent this is
how I know that they don't have any
sense of stakes cuz I'm a giant and I'm
you know there's no fear sometimes in
these people yeah you could they're just
like you're the worst during why you're
a man like words or violence and I'm
like it no point in my life would I ever
that would be like me looking at an
8-foot man yeah yeah I like on it like I
could eat you do you need help do you
want me to rub your feet you know it's
like how do you not have that fear of
just violence yes and because I'm very
anti violence but
because you know I tell that to people
so I'm like dude don't forget sermon on
the mount or you'll get Leviticus again
you know to me like those are like that
bass is still there like we've expanded
it to this freedom and the lack of race
you know yeah but you can go right back
to that if people start forgetting about
the work it took to get these Freda
that's right I remember in Exodus it
says thou shalt not suffer a witch to
live perhaps you know we've got to go
back to some of this more fundamental
understanding I don't know that that is
so right and the Millennials they're so
afraid of or they're so coddled rather
that they don't have that sense of
reality you'll talk to them and you'll
just think like have you never rubbed up
against reality for even one second
never once know their atrophy its
attributes like muscle atrophy it's like
when you have a cast and then your wrist
looks weird yeah it's like in it for
it's not like there's I remember where a
concept of like spoiled it's not like
big big they got everything taken from
them with this it's not like there's no
jealousy there because they now can't
function mm-hmm they like have no
ability of like functioning the world
and and I think it's you know a bad
parenting it's a cancer on them it's
like their parents must it's like Fight
Club it's like that absentee father the
absentee God that they're like no one
cared about me they just sent me out and
then someone's always watching me yeah
that's right that's right yeah it there
is like I've noticed this with people
people who have actually suffered in
life they go one of two ways either they
like go to jail or they are the most
joyful people on earth yeah I had that
North Korean defector ji seong-ho came
in here this guy I don't know that I'll
ever meet someone who has suffered like
I saw is that was going into North Korea
are you going it's utopian socialist
Democrat why would you want to leave why
would you ever want is utopian I saw I'm
crawling out of it as I was crying and
okay are you leaving what's going on
dude don't you want freedom yeah but
don't you want safety breadline yeah oh
shoot that's so so what have so this so
I talked to him and I and I noticed I
thought like this is the most joyful
person I've ever met so now whenever are
like you know I don't know I stubbed my
toe on my chair say ah my toe you know
and my wife she'll say like oh yeah
should I call gee somehow get a note you
know like and that humans adjust it come
on is the stasis here but that when I
see these millennial types whining
because like they can't just be
professional poets yeah I have to like
get a job too
I just think like man me you gotta talk
to G song home lover because it's like
uh yeah the inability of feeling joy
that's the thing is even if they did
become a famous rapper or something they
still would never be happy they'll be
crying on a yacht it's like this yacht
is dogs it's like the same nightmare is
just always flat yeah yeah same
nightmare sheets with a higher thread
count yeah yeah that is it I mean I just
like looking around this is why I'm very
into owning the libs I kind of I
disagree respectfully with our
ambassador to the UN on this owning yes
it's great because it's it's so
attractive it's there's such a joy to it
there's an exuberance yeah and you
compare that joy to this relentless
tedious self serious leftism why would
you ever pick that got it on the lips
I'm not advocating killing the way yeah
what up just possess them that's why we
showed that without vegans like I'm
always like I wouldn't eat a person you
know you just try to let go so far look
I'm look like I love compassion I'm a
moderate yeah I would never eat a human
being I don't think yeah maybe not and
ease but I don't know what happens yeah
it's like no like make it III think
leftism is such a destructive force that
I I don't know why people are like
saying that it's I don't know I'm like
no you got to take it out any way you
can get it out just get it cuz it's like
and be funny with it I mean there if the
best comedy they can do if the comedy
that the left has which gets Netflix
hour-long specials is not comedy then
like make them laugh man people just
want to laugh they want to smile they
wondered I'd love it you know yeah I
thought my career was done because of
like certain opinions I had and it's
totally not opinions like we shouldn't
castrate children literally since yeah
yeah that opinion got you fired from all
races all deserve jokes about them yes
that's oh there's nothing more kind of
setting like there'd be jokes I'd write
with like a bunch of black dudes I'm on
the road with and some like just white
girl and like always a white girl always
a white girl and they're like excuse me
excuse me my neighbor's male man's best
friend is named Tyrone and you're like
what are you talking about like it's so
infuriating cory booker's imaginary
friend t-bone would be very offended by
that joke yes it's like invisible black
people around them I got this one time
and you're like if you actually see
human beings as individuals yeah you
never know when the potholes coming
because you don't see people as
demographics that's right you know what
you're more into height is unlikely I
you can't know but I just honestly I
think obviously I'm not a - but like I
think height is way more divisive than
race as far as what your day is like
totally there actually is height
privilege that is true there always you
know yes but then it goes farther like
I'm almost six eight yeah you're on the
back end of that but yeah sure I can't
be on a roller coaster no one in a
nursing home is over five ten you know
like I'm the first one arrested you know
like there's all kinds of stuff you know
heads a grab like a great day and like
hips go out at like 40 yeah you know you
know your mistake though when you were
when you were making jokes about all the
races if you had only made jokes about
white white men and even if you just
said really vicious things about white
men you could be on the New York Times
yeah doors Hillary Clinton I could just
like rape someone no I'm dead serious
it's true babies happen I know you might
have had to donate you might have had to
donate a little too yeah Harvey
Weinstein was in like openly raping
people and and and and they were calling
him god that's right it's like what I
just said seems so shocking but people
laugh good people just laugh because
it's it's there's so much truth in it
that you're like that's true you can get
away with anything I was at like and I
think Hui CK is an incredible joke
writer but like um I'll watch some of
his bits I'm like the way he's talking
about his wife and kids I'm like you
know I'm like dude you know he's like my
daughter's it I don't want to say that
in show out of respect and I'm like whoa
man yeah you know yeah it seems to be a
little what that's like the James Gunn
thing right you guys say it's all jokes
and you think
maybe but yes'm why did you I disagree
with Shapiro and now I think he actually
might have been right cuz the dude is
such an assassin like when you when
you're debating with him you're like
woah oh yeah
easy Paganini can sell spoiled milk to a
cow I mean it dude I was I was convinced
that he was wrong about it yeah and and
I I realized he's actually right about
it cuz vert cuz he was talking about if
you know what you're getting into when
you hire someone you gotta just eat that
that's true right yeah and so that makes
sense because like my point was like no
we have to have standards we can't go
down that road of like we're becoming
our enemies if we don't hire a known
pedophile to babysit our kids you know
it's like no this is right and wrong and
and it's like that's gonna take a hit
out of the business the fact that he
writes these things yes but I mean what
he's saying isn't funny and I know
people have said that to me where
they're like your joke isn't funny I'm
like cuz you don't understand hyperbole
irony and assumptions yeah but yeah okay
cuz lefties are known for their great
sense of humor that's really good right
and like even like describe what the
joke is and how it's the opposite of
what they think it is I still don't get
it of course so I don't want to fall
down that road and say James Gunn
shouldn't do these jokes well I don't
personally think you should but he
should not be around kids professionally
as I'm saying yeah I just love it
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy
he was the first season to cheer when
they all got fired for jokes and now it
comes back and bites him and and it is
great because you know these guys are
dying by their own hypocrisy you're like
living in freedom I mean you're and it's
like you just have a happier life like I
would get those like lefty development
deals that you don't deserve and all
that stuff but you don't enjoy it again
it's almost like biblical it's like you
get on the world and you get nothing you
know that's so true so what were you up
to where can people see you where can
people find you well my website is a
huge pianist com I have three specials
they're self produced from the last year
and a half and then I'm the preggers you
video watching Sheeran I desperately
want a deep beat Dave Rubin cuz he gets
a little cocky buddy oh yeah that's
right uh and yeah just YouTube Dennis's
birthday party those are places they can
go huge can't wait calm yeah and we're
so you figure a James Gunn has a Twitter
Isis as a Twitter where can they find
you on Twitter not on Twitter well this
is what I got kicked off Twitter
permanently for an a joke that if
I could say edit in a Catholic preschool
not not not quite but literally nothing
and the more time goes on the more
people are like this joke making fun a
day vlog yeah well you know James Gunn
gets to stay on on Twitter but you don't
do that Farrakhan is on Twitter Eric on
yeah hates Shapiro this pers race yeah
that's true
dude the leftists all races and it's
like these guys are on there talking
about Jews are like a disease
I'm like why but you're a huge pianist
then I'm gonna let you want no without
me around I'm a quarter Jewish so that
kicks in hard I'm like excuse me and I
didn't even find out it was Jewish until
I was 20 but I always knew I was up to
something you were like you were the
Tamar that's a good bit you it's true
story I thought of my grandmother's
totally Jewish they don't even now is
that that is true yeah he were your the
tallest juice in Samson almost I know
that's why I never cut my hair recently
yeah that no but lose fair cuz on
Twitter like that's insane that it's
true it isn't saying it's amazing like
he's in Genesis like the way he talks
about Jews is genocide --all but yeah
because I don't like gun rights that's
right that's right that's terrible I'm
sorry my Twitter's gonna die anyway like
Facebook and Twitter stocks are just
plunging that's why they hate the free
market because nonsense is rewarded with
a lack of money yeah yeah that's true
that's absolutely right and well so I'm
gonna see you tomorrow well yeah and I
want everywhere by the left is tears mug
you gotta give her on tumblr you got to
get it the only way to get this by the
way people because I gotta say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube I've given you
too much today I've got to say goodbye
this is hot and cold it what about
lukewarm tears you're not allowed to
have it that way go outside stand in the
middle of the road get hit by a truck go
to daily wire.com subscribe now get the
leftist ears tumblr we'll be right back
unfortunately without Owen Owen thanks
for being oh dude I blast Cheers
for those who didn't catch that I just
said goodbye to Owen and he stood up and
cracked his head on our ceiling lights
that Owen is on the other side of high
privilege he is not on the good side of
height privilege man it's always good to
have him here it's like a like the
Tasmanian devil likes ten Tasmanian
Devils come through as is so funny and
he's like got such a fresh perspective
it's so good that this guy isn't being
like just owned by studios he's on his
own I mean Freedom Works now this brings
us to our final point today we're
running a little late so I'll try to
cover it quickly there's another side to
freedom when people abuse their freedom
when they use their freedom to break the
laws to hurt other people to violate the
moral law then we we can kill them then
the state can kill them again this has
been true at all times it's acknowledged
in the epistles it's acknowledged in
Christianity it's always been the
position of the Catholic Church and
today Pope Francis has amended certain
aspects of church teaching and the in
the Catechism of the Catholic Church to
say that the death penalty now is
inadmissible that's his word the death
penalty by civil governments is in
admissible so we'll go into what that
means a little bit and some of the
thoughts on the health benefits of
capital punishment but the lefty
politicians are cheering so fake
Catholic politicians like the Cuomo's
for instance the Cuomo's Mario Cuomo
invented this whole I oppose abortion
but I think it should be legal line well
I'm personally opposed to abortion but I
support abortion and they're trying to
have their cake and eat it too and it's
and it's absurd because abortion is
intrinsically evil
so Andy Cuomo was running with this Andy
Cuomo his son the governor of New York
tweets out today quote the death penalty
is morally indefensible has no place in
the 21st century today in solidarity
with Pontifex and in honor of my father
I will be advancing legislation to
remove the death penalty from state law
once and for all this is the same guy by
the way Andy Cuomo who said that if
you're not in favor of abortion you're
not in New York or you have no play
in New York this is a radical lefty and
he's he quotes this church when it's
convenient so what is it with what is it
with the death penalty is is the death
penalty morally acceptable well what
what Pope Francis wrote today is this
this is the new teaching of the Catholic
catechism the Catechism of the Catholic
Church is the book of teachings of the
Catholic Church there was a version that
came out of leave in 1992 is it from
john paul ii and it formerly said that
the death penalty in modern society
while not intrinsically evil would be
practically non-existent because we have
other ways of dealing with criminals
it's now changed to recourse to the
death penalty on the part of legitimate
authority following a fair trial was
long considered an appropriate response
to the gravity of certain crimes and an
acceptable albeit extreme means of
safeguarding the common good today
however there is an increasing awareness
that the dignity of the person is not
lost even after the commission of very
serious crimes in addition a new
understanding has emerged of the
significance of penal sanctions imposed
by the state lastly more effective
systems have been developed consequently
the Church teaches in light of the
gospel that quote the death penalty is
inadmissible because it is an attack on
the inviolability and dignity of the
person mmm-hmm well I don't know so
inadmissible what is inadmissible me
what is it really saying you know
because the the Pope is not allowed to
change doctrine that that doesn't happen
people mistake this frequently because
of people don't understand papal
infallibility the the Pope can't change
doctrine of the church he can articulate
doctor and he and clarify doctrine so
inadmissible that's not the same as
saying it's intrinsically evil
inadmissible means not capable of being
admitted or conceded or allowed scope
for or conceded as valid okay
tricky wording isn't it was it always
inadmissible no it certainly wasn't
always inadmissible st. Agustin writes
about this he says the same divine
authority that forbids the killing of a
human being establishes certain
exceptions as when God authorizes
killing by a general law or when he
gives in
plus a commission to an individual for a
period of time Thomas Aquinas is the
same thing it is permissible to kill a
criminal if this is necessary for the
welfare of the whole community
now look Pope Benedict is this isn't a
total break with Pope Francis Pope
Benedict said quote there may be a
legitimate diversity of opinion among
Catholics about waging war and applying
the death penalty so there can be some
disagreement it doesn't mean that now if
you're Pro death penalty
you are not Catholic or something like
that certainly not but I would like to
bring in a little bit of history before
we go here on on the death penalty and
the church and the health benefits of
capital punishment in Rome in 1817 Pope
Pius the seventh was reigning three
robbers were beheaded they were beheaded
for robbery between 1814 and 1870 369
criminals were beheaded in the papal
States under the control of the Pope he
you know I got to take care of those
criminals Giovanni Battista Bugatti who
is the official papal executioner used
an axe to chop off criminals heads
before the guillotine was brought in to
be more humane the Pope between 1814 and
1817 just three years sanctioned the
hanging drawing and quartering of
criminals eleven separate times heinous
crimes particularly heinous crimes were
not treated in this way instead those
criminals had their heads crushed with
the matzo telo mallet that's a little
stronger that's that doesn't seem to be
quite in keeping with the modern
teaching AGGA Tino Bellomo who was the
last to be executed in the papal States
asked to Blessed Pius the 9th for a stay
of execution Blessed Pius the 9th
responded to him this is the last person
executed there and said I cannot and I
do not want to and then he was executed
the issue here is that capital
punishment protects human rights
it protects human beings human life and
the natural right another natural law
rather so there there are different
kinds of punishment
there is retributive punishment
punishment just for Justice's sake there
is deterrent punishment so when when
people are punished harshly for a crime
it discourages others from doing that
there is a therapeutic punishment you
know you can put
one into a rehabilitation center you say
oh you know the purpose of putting
someone in prison is to rehabilitate
them okay that's that's one of them too
and there is a medicinal punishment
medicinal capital punishment which is
that the Samuel Johnson quote when a man
knows to be hanged in a that he's going
to be hanged in a fortnight it
concentrates his mind wonderfully when
you know that you're going to be killed
for your crime it clarifies the world a
little bit if the the whole point of the
Catholic teaching on capital punishment
excuse me is that we want to bring
people to Christ we want to give them a
time to repent well when you're looking
at that guillotine over there it focuses
your mind it really brings certain
questions to mind a a more modern
example of this because you can talk
about all the papal States and Pope's
chopping off people's heads and and all
that is very good but consider the
Nuremberg trials during the Nuremberg
trials of all the Nazi war criminals who
slaughtered and genocided whole scores
of people a Pope Pius the 12th was so
eager for justice that he sent his
jesuit archivist to assist the
prosecutors at the Nuremberg trials Pope
Pius the 12th personally told the
prosecutor Robert Jackson quote not only
do we approve of the trial but we desire
that the guilty be punished as quickly
as possible
one of the defining features of this
pontificate is some confusion there
seems to be a lot of confusion on
matters of divorce matters of who can
receive the Communion matters of capital
punishment matters of church teaching
evolution where things are going I mean
the evolution of the church not to
monkeys turning into people there seems
to be a lot of confusion and it would be
nice to have some clarity because the
church has had moral clarity on this
issue for a very long time and the if
the confusion persists and suggests that
capital punishment is intrinsic evil
then first of all church tradition will
be changed a doctrine of the thoughts of
the church will be changed but it's
really morally unclear because there's
nothing Christian about letting the
wicked rake the face of the earth
letting the cruel will rape the face of
the earth there's nothing Christian
about that and let's hope that that
confusion doesn't persist any longer I
told you
top of the show when Catholics have
trouble with things that are coming out
of the Vatican you know you know you're
like very very respectful about it there
was a group of clergy who formally
accused Pope Francis of heresy but the
way that you do it in the Catholic
Church is you it's called a a filial
letter of correction for heresy like
Most Holy Father we think we may have
misunderstood what you were saying you
know very very respectful so let's hope
respectfully we can get some clarity on
all of those matters and people don't
forget the important medicinal effects
of hanging and having your head chopped
off in the mean time you know we started
recording another Kingdom and other
kingdoms coming up get ready for you got
to binge that first season so you're
ready for season two it is really really
cool I'll tell you that in the meantime
I'll see you soon I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show see you
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolan is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
board senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018